population is over nine percent veterans
that's over two hundred thousand people
that have served our country but some of
them exposed to toxic substances while
serving cannot always get medical
treatment for it but as Ryan mathie
shows us a new law means a new
opportunity for veterans to receive care
a lot of us leave the military and say
we're fine we're fine because that's
what we've been taught to do while
serving our country some veterans were
served health problems for life
with fuel on your running down your arms
you used to die Iraq on your elbow so
that it wouldn't run down into your
armpit hair loss menstrual problems
hypertension just to name a few from
exposure to burn pits agent orange and
other toxic substances while serving
during the Vietnam Gulf War and post-9
11 eras getting treatment for these
exposures was not always covered by the
VA but under recent legislation
thousands of more veterans could be
headed to VA Medical Centers like the
one here in North Las Vegas now that
several other medical conditions are
presumed to be service related and now
covered if there was an exposure we've
got to take care of them and their
families it's through the pact act
enacted in January that expands and
extends eligibility for veterans looking
to treat problems caused by toxic
exposure in some instances it's also
expanded to the veterans family
Democratic Nevada senator Catherine
Cortez masto says it adds 23 conditions
to the presumptive list which disregards
the need to prove eligibility for
benefits if you were exposed you you
have every right now under the packed
act to receive that that access to
health care
since President Biden signed The Pact
act in August nearly 2500 new veterans
enrolled for Veterans Affair care that's
according to the VA dashboard the VA
expects up to twenty thousand new
members because of this bill